hey I'm Kasey Musgraves and I'm here at
BuzzFeed I'm gonna answer your questions
and play with some puppies okay alright
bring him on in oh my god hey friend
come here come here
oh my good you like my hair spray
alright first question what's something
Texas
never mind what is the story of the
first time you ever smoked the devil's
lettuce I was in high school and we were
all hanging out with this guy named
sprinkles and I tried it and it didn't
do anything and I was like this is
boring hey oh oh you're the one who just
urinated why are you wet what do you
think about Lady gaga and are you going
to see as strong as Warren yeah I'm
gonna go I'm going tonight I think she's
very talented and I'm excited to see
movie I have a lot of friends that wrote
songs for movie so I'm excited to see
how those turned out what do you think
of candy corn I think it's pretty what
do you think of candy corn is that your
name
what city are you most excited to visit
on your upcoming tour I really like
Copenhagen and I've never gotten to play
a show there I've just kind of rolled
through it and it's super unique and fun
I'm excited about that answer damn hey
you I want you I mean this one is kind
of like the mature one of the group I
think I think he's look at this one oh
man if you had the opportunity to say
something to Donald Trump to his face
what would you say
I don't know hopefully I'm never that
close who came up with the idea to sing
you're still the one at Madison Square
Garden night too
when you're on tour with Harry Caray
well I did text me when I said we should
do it
a song and he makes that one what's your
go-to karaoke song um I really liked
goodbye our old by the Dixie Chicks I
loved skater boy after living I love any
Celine Dion specifically my heart will
go on or that's the way it is of all the
famous people you've met who is exactly
like we thought they'd be funny timing
for this because a few days ago I got
some the Adele for the first time and
she was exactly like you think she would
be just open the door with no makeup and
um just was really like kind and
open-hearted and funny profane and
seemingly like unaffected by all of our
success and I really admire those
qualities and it was really funny I love
her do you believe in ghosts
yeah def there's probably someone here
right now but it's a more fun world for
me to like imagine that there's like a
spirit of spiritual side of things
oh my god it's a little literally
tornado of puppies will we ever find out
who high horse is about calling us it's
about a lot of people though actually
like multiple being attacked help me no
just kidding okay so this one says
you've recently been vocal about the
lack of inclusivity for female country
music artists what do you think it will
take to turn the tide and get country
music back to a time where women roll
like the time of Loretta and Tammy and
Dolly well I'm not sure we'll ever
really get back to the time of Loretta
and Tammy and Ellie that was an anomaly
that will never happen again I don't
know you know there's so much focus on
gender equality and country music and
it's such a tiring subject for me
because to me there's so many areas of
inequality in country music that I want
to see change happen in I think there
should be more country artists of color
I think there should be country artists
you know that are representing the LGBTQ
community from their perspective and
even just like sonic differences like in
songs aren't allowed really to be that
popular a lot of things like sound the
same and so it's not just gender it's a
lot of things subject matter in equality
I mean hopefully over time that that
will open and if not then people will
turn elsewhere for to find the music
that inspires them what's your favorite
Britney Spears song email my heart just
kidding not that one oh I love toxic Oh
what's your Hogwarts house that's a good
question I just recently got in a Harry
Potter and I own the late bloomer so
it's what ravenclaw hufflepuffs
Slytherin bat Gryffindor I'm gonna go
for the classy Gryffindor like that's
what that's the house you wanted me if
not that then maybe like Ravenclaw it's
a helpful place like a bunch well there
is just like it's a negative zone what's
been your favorite song to perform I
love singing slow burn for some reason I
have a big connection to this song it
feels very personal to me and whatever
key it's in is like really comfortable
for me to sing so it just feels like
water like flowing I don't know it just
feels really good I don't have to push
but it's always fun singing like
merry-go-round arrow because like
everyone s words best thing about being
married
knowing that no matter what somebody has
your back and that you have somebody
else's back it's a really wonderful
feeling and I genuinely never thought
that I would get married I was that
person it was like I did not see this
happening for myself then the right
person came along and just like I knew
right away that it was that he was right
and it's awesome we we support each
other and it's hard sometimes because
we're both artists and we're about to
not see each other for a while but
but it bought it um cool well we have
one more question
Oh rank your top three condiments
sriracha sriracha and sriracha and get
mustard and mayo away from me I don't
even want to don't even try to put that
on my sandwich thank you so much it's
been so much fun all of these puppies
are available for adoption from North
Shore Animal League America I'm Kacey
Musgraves thanks so much for watching
[Music]